the two days summit in the ethiopian
capital concluded with a call for
greater african representation on the
global stage
seventy years after the creation of the
united nations au leaders complained
that africa was still unrepresented on
the u.n security council
they are demanding at least two
prominent and five non-permanent seats
it is the right time
to reform and revitalize the united
nations system to reflect
current global realities and ensure that
it is a more representative and
equitable body
only fair representation
and transparency in those institutions
can usher in a just era in
multilateralism
the past 18 months have been chaotic for
africa with crews in chad guinea malibu
nafaso and sudan
as well as the protracted civil war here
in ethiopia
the eu has been accused of an
inconsistent response notably by not
suspending chad from the 55-member
organization after the military took
over following the death of long-time
leader idris debbie
every african
leader
in the assembly
has condemned
unequivocally
the
pattern of the resurgence of the cycle
or the wave
of unconstitutional changes of
government
the african union's efforts to combat
the covet 19 pandemic were also
discussed at length after a long delay
african nations began receiving larger
donations of covet 19 magazines in
november but the continent is still far
behind global vaccination targets partly
due to what some say are logistical
challenges
governments now hope the au's creation
of a continent-wide drug regulator the
african medicine's agency helps them
roll out vaccines to catch up with other
parts of the world
and differences between members over the
union's relationship with israel broke
into the open
palestinian prime minister muhammad
shitai made an impassioned plea to
leaders to reconsider their decision to
give israel observer status at au
meetings we believe that granting israel
observer status at the african union is
undeserved reward this actually
a reward that encourages israel to
continue violating international
treaties breaching all agreements with
us
the prime minister was supported by some
important member states including
nigeria and south africa whose ruling
party the african national congress
supports the palestinian cause
in the end the palestinian argument was
worn and leaders agreed to suspend
israel's observer status
muhammad al-jazeera addison